[Music]
today we are playing $100 wine burst box
wine verse hot sauce that makes sense
right let's get into it
Jordan the wine expert I'm pretty
confident I've taken a four-week wine
course in Bordeaux whoa I guess one of
the world's most famous wine regions I
did drink a lot of wine there and so I
think I might know the difference
between expensive and inexpensive what I
actually took some notes for you guys so
the difference between an expensive and
a cheap wine might be an expensive wine
might use premium single varietal grapes
oh and hot sauce can be distinguished by
the fact that it is hot sauce and not
intended to be consumed as a drink and
the hot sauce that we're drinking today
is a habanero this is our $100 bottle of
wine and this is our cheap $2 box wine I
think it's time to get into it
Hannah you're gonna go first please put
on your blindfold the rules of the game
are while blindfolded Hannah will
randomly select one of these three shots
which I will mix up now and then she
must be able to tell which is the cheap
wine which is the expensive wine and
which is the hot sauce so by rules of
three you might realize that if she can
get it right in the first two she
doesn't need to taste the third one so
there's a world here where she doesn't
taste that hot sauce if that happens and
she definitely identifies the wine she's
going to pass that hot sauce down to
Chris who might end up drinking two hot
sauces let's play $100 wine first box
why in verse hot sauce Hannah please
pick D Taylor shot getting to the tubs
yeah I'm just gonna okay there are three
and they've been mixed up that's one
that's the first one okay take your time
and as a reminder Hannah once it's
picked up
you have to drink the one you chose oh
geez picked a live is it don't say what
you think I can't I can't smell it you
can't smell it but you have to consider
this is a hard time when we Jordan your
I know it's not hot sauce okay great any
good small yeah you get a loogie in your
throat to lubricate the line what are
you thinking I mean this is the
expensive one okay you can try one more
before you give us your final answer I
think I need two full glasses and see
how I feel tomorrow there's two next to
each other you're touching one
peck okay give a smell you have to
consume this you have to consume this
give us now trying to snort it okay
shake yep shaking around we need an
answer I mean this is the front yet
final answer correct yes Hannah take off
that blindfold you are correctly
identified that was the back line the
first one who's the expensive so that
means that your hot sauce is getting
passed down to you Crescent there are
now four cups in front of you two of
them are the hot sauce one is the $100
one and one is the cheap wine took me to
the kites just adored I'm clumsy so I'm
not to knock anything over these are
okay that's three and then there's a
fourth
okay this is all it right here like it's
all hot sauce hot sauces I'm going with
this one
do it do it you got it okay so what'd
you think I was lying or hot songs or we
rule into a ball okay so you gotta
choose the next one I'm mixing them up
again for the rules okay
good my hand there are three glasses now
remain okay Wow such a slow moving
liquid oh good job good job we've got
some milk for you I'll trade ya if you
want it good stupid watch where's the
water all right there's two two glasses
remains okay okay pick all right so what
do you think that was had that taste
expensive or cheap one cheap lie
[Applause]
I've ever seen Chris cotton I love you
okay so Jordan please put the blindfold
on on Jordan I want you to talk me
through what was what did you learn in
that four-week class that you that you
think will be able to put you over the
top today okay so I know that on your
tongue there are like different like
areas that taste different parts of the
wine uh-huh
and like the back I think is the tannin
part okay but to be honest I just really
I drink a lot in the classes and I
didn't really you impress your teachers
known right after actually made it hot
[Laughter]
without any further ado Jordan I will
guard your hand there are three glasses
in front of you two of them are wine and
one of them is hot sauce it's up to you
now to choose and once you pick one you
have to finish okay your pick there we
go what do you what are you thinking
it's well okay so I think it's hot -
okay interesting
it could be like a more robust wine
though one of those thick wines okay
here we go there you go yeah they don't
see it that's a fun game good job good
job
this was Jordan's idea this game was
Jordans idea okay - all right you know
we've got napkins and a spit bucket and
milk if you need it to remain so what
are you thinking right now
so Tiffany you're looking good
I can't smell my clothes I can't take a
sip gonna try the last three all right
we were having a little fun with you
there Jordan there's two to remain now
okay give it a try see if you can beat
Chris Chris and Hannah have both
correctly gotten theirs right
and either of em took a four week board
oh let's see watch your mother will get
hotter just so you know afterwards
oops boy tell me what you're tasting
what are you feeling
this tastes kind of cheap I don't know
like hurts you know it's a cool way to
hold the glass
like this are you using the table to
swirl it alright so wine you're drinking
this is the expensive one yes be sure if
I nine hundred percent sure you want to
taste one last time of the cheap one to
make sure we got right here they'll pass
this has been $100 wine verse box wine
verse putz huh let us know in the
comments what blind taste us we should
do next time thanks for watching please
like comment subscribe whoo good job Hey
[Music]